if you're ready to make a statement and
your next celebration our guest today
can get it done you may have seen her
amazing creations
on social media but now we have the
owner here with us
eileen entertainment and it is savannah
thank you for joining us today
now this is fun i've seen you on tick
tock i've seen you on instagram and you
create these amazing works of art
balloon art
floral design and it all kind of started
when covet hit explain what happened
so i was doing event planning and
obviously since covet hit we couldn't do
events anymore so we decided
what can we do and we were already kind
of experienced with balloons a little
bit in floral
so we kind of just started selling
products instead of services
and then since everybody was at home
they kind of wanted to send a loved one
flowers or balloons to cheer up their
day and
basically the business blew up in a
couple months and we're here now well
the way you do it is so original so
innovative and it's unlike anything i've
ever seen before and you're going to
actually show me
how to put together one of your amazing
arrangements let's let's do this you had
me pick a few flowers at the beginning
of the segment that i liked
so we've got a sunflower what else do we
have we have a lily and we have a little
dragon too
okay i think these are these are so
different like how is this going to make
a beautiful bouquet i want to see
so we're known for our little singles
and these are always available in store
for 15
okay and then basically we'll have some
pre-made or like today we'll have the
client choose like their favorite things
that they see
and this is with our
korean paper which is waterproof and you
can just stick this in a vase
right after at home you don't have to
unwrap the pretty wrapping
and then we'll usually have like a
florist or two up front
just making their magic and it's just
putting them all together with a little
zip tie it's a little
pretty simple i've always wondered how
they stayed intact like that
and this paper talk a little bit about
this paper because they come in so many
different colors and they're like slick
they're different than your typical
tissue paper they get all wet when you
have the flowers
so it's korean paper and koreans make
all of their floral arrangements like
that and it's just been hitting like the
u.s like
really popular lately so it's awesome
because it's paper that's not going to
get soggy or wet or anything like that
when you stick it in a vase you're just
able to
display your flowers just as beautiful
as when you pick them up from the shop
and i love that it comes in different
colors and then also designs like that
one looks like marble over there
okay what are we going to go with today
so we're gonna do some pink wrapping
and usually what we do in the store is
we'll have a little moisture pack under
just so
we can make sure when you get home
they're still fresh and nice
but so we learn how to do kind of like
the korean fold
oh how is this you gotta show us so it's
just like a quick diagonal
okay and then you grab your flowers you
want to make sure she's fluffy
that looks so pretty i know if i did it
would look like
a bunch of garbage packs how long does
this take
in to to put this all together to order
to order
yes if i wanted to get one of these made
for oh so in person
it's i guess it depends on the floors if
you ask me it'll be like five minutes
someone else probably like 15.
yeah i like that she's like i'm faster
than everyone else
i've just i've made probably thousands
of bouquets at this point
and if people want to order how do they
get in touch with you so you can visit
us in-store we take walk-ins or we also
have a website called eileen
entertainment.com where you can just
customize everything on there
and our website's fun because we don't
just have like pre-made things on there
you can just choose colors
flowers everything on there super
customized beautiful i know we're
running out of time you're putting the
finishing touches but yeah
look at these balloons we've got
different floral arrangements and so
anything you need you can check out the
social media and look it it's done
i just picked four random flowers and
look at that she created this work of
art
again the website social media so the
social media is ileane.entertainment
and then website eileen
entertainment.com and you can pretty
much find us all just by typing eileen
entertainment
anywhere that's a social media platform
and we're going to make some more over
here
we'll be back